un restaurant en plein centre-ville de
montréal complètement désert pour le
chef jérôme ferrer les derniers jours
ont été difficiles
c'est l'effondrement c'est
l'effondrement il accueille normalement
plus de 120 clients par jour
mais ils ont presque tous disparu
d'imaginer pouvoir se relever d'une
telle catastrophe c'est c'est difficile
pour moi aujourd'hui je prends
conscience tout simplement que peut-être
je vis mes derniers instants comme chef
propriétaire de mon restaurant qui est
tout nouveau
on n'ose pas imaginer tout ça ici nous
on se serre les coudes et pas
le restaurant compte une centaine
d'employés jérôme ferrer met tout en
oeuvre pour qu'ils aient du travail
demain de leur dire simplement je tire
la plogue je m'en vais moi je suis pas
capable de le faire
ici aussi le silence règne les salles à
manger des saint-hubert comme celle de
beaucoup d'autres restaurants au québec
sont fermés le gouvernement leur
permettaient pourtant d'accueillir 50 %
de la clientèle
même à 5 1% ça fait beaucoup d'employés
de personnes qui se côtoient des
employés devient un peu moins à l'aise
avant tout le sentent et nos employés
nos clients
c'est ça qui prime les clients qui se
bute à des portes closes se rabat sur la
livraison et le service au volant on n'a
pas même un joueur on veut manger à ma
faim
on mange la drac le restaurant europea
veut aussi offrir cette alternative
en 24 heures il a mis en place un
service de commandes à emporter pour
tenter de sauver les meubles
je dis aux gens quelles que soient vos
chefs préférés votre restauration
fétiche à travers toute la province du
québec
s'il est possible de vous arrêter chez
eux en voiture récupérer un sac de repas
de mets préparés fait pas juste le
bonheur des multinationales et des des
gros industriels
un petit geste qui pourrait sauver de
nombreux emplois ici sébastien
desrosiers radio canada morrell